for that
sue wears really
[ __ ] ah come on Oh not the water monster
please
it's like a flash
ah what's in here
Antrim and run Chan
portal potion why what is this
chemical where's the key then
[ __ ] I'm just worried that the frickin
water monster and it's like whoo I'm
literally walking in poo here yes works
oh this is great this is exactly how
laboratories it looks like isn't it
[ __ ] prison cell oh oh what the the
[ __ ] what gangbang sex always ends like
this
they'll wake up soon with full of
regrets and full of hurt hurting bottles
but I know I've been there
what Strunk you mix it's a long sorry
anyway uh I need Stefano
I bet easier some I stink ass awesome
yes finally finally finally yes it's a
fun oh where are you oh it feels so good
yes yeah yeah there's obviously nothing
here
mmm
gangbanged room already been there
what what was that ah ok no problem
problem problem problems everywhere [ __ ]
you - [ __ ] ok we need Frankie
oh why barrels a virus alright barrels
of barrels at me my leg it's no problem
system on oh [ __ ]
in danger follow the blood I mean the
period that's what we're doing so let's
go let's go oh [ __ ] it ah ah uh uh I
don't wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna
I really don't wanna ah come on
just don't hello anyone in here that arm
is gonna extract my penis from it Oh
sign your new penis and I'm gonna use my
arm for it ha ha uh uh why did you close
I can't believe I fell for that ah okay
okay pickup I want it oh man
deliciousness mm-hmm I'm gonna stay here
turn off the camera and do what I do
best
hmm
mm-hmm but that's for later can I open
this again maybe there's a key in it no
of course not
same lady funky Savano where is Stefano
seriously though like extract blood from
how like with the needle nope
no but seriously though it did something
but that's what we did the last time I
don't understand my oh my oh my and I
love the sound it makes maybe from his
penis oh yeah that makes sense
no it doesn't make sense mmm no says
broma hand of a twisted okay I guess ISM
I should look for those three sink
things
okay so
maybe I need to place this somewhere
first
I don't understand
ouch
I thought for sure that was right I
followed the period
I mean look have I missed something in
here Oh
what is this have I been in here No
blast those damn watts plug my last
bottle of mercury I knew I should have
figured out the poison for them
fortunately for me however due to the
advances of modern technology
I can smell of junk and cinnabar in to
help okay I need all I need to do in
this place it in what hot enough fire
and the software will separate it on his
own I should be careful though
extracting blah blah blah uh-huh uh-huh
modern technology a small chunk of
ginger beer in America reading all I
need to do is fight it in a holiday in
alpha L a nibble and the software will
argue but mm-hmm it seems odd place for
mine durpa durpa durpa I'm used I was
hoping there could be something
maybe in here it looks like perfect
place to put Aladdin am latinum and a
change box maybe in his closet he kept
his secrets he didn't keep any secrets
in his closet I'm [ __ ] quite what is
this
nope that's nothing great I'm so happy
and so happy have it looked everywhere
though yeah I pretty much looked
everywhere hmm all right welcome back to
abduction um we're in the sewers I can't
get off this [ __ ] ladder thing I
think it's we need to whip ourselves
over here because I missed something as
usual there's supposed to be a key I
think maybe I don't know I don't know
let's go to the laboratory that looks
like a freaking prison or whatever
I'm scared a little scared I could be
scared I'm scared
yeah I'm pretty scared I just started I
was like
anything right anyway
scary stuff will happen there will be
period on the floor is in here yes yes
yeah yes sorry I get excited sometimes
we got the keys and now we can go
through the chemical storage got a
little my chemical it's not exit
oh I haven't have only these now
excellent alright let's go back to the
sewers and swim in the poop and diarrhea
and phew and all those nice things that
came out of Alexander spot mm-hmm I'm
loving it
I'm having this so much uh-huh
is there anything no all right let's
just key to open I'm a genius
I'm a genius gonna move you backwards
cuz I don't know I just
Oh ah this doesn't look good ah no no
I have no
ah it's so dark as usual in his mom
uh-huh what
okay I'll disco oh I don't I don't just
you ah don't problem nope it's just such
yes yes
you I don't trust I told you many times
in this mud I don't trust her ah but I
don't trust you I don't trust you I
don't trust you stop I don't want to
make out okay but maybe
oh I see see you later punk huh
think it's tough I'm gonna stand in this
thing oh that was bad idea wasn't it
get up Daniel we're not done dad out ah
sorry all right let's go let's go
I Miss Piggy I miss the funnel I miss
everyone is this where we came from I
yeah it was it was uh super creepy
super confusing
I'm gonna go insane for sure by playing
this game okay let's go here then so
many doors and walls oh ah ah ah I don't
want to see this man boobs
oh man I wasn't ready for that at all
okay we got the bromine that's good it's
good where you got bromine and what else
do we need
I mean Plan B what
blast to up at the pump
ah come on I think I read it somewhere
oh whatever
let's go we got bromine anything that
has bro in it is a good thing I think
bro mine mine bro mine bro craft
bro mine anyway okay first and then
second right no they're both frying very
best leave your lap
I better leave these alone then but
these however ah-ha-ha most of all to
clean this up oh sweet
and we have you
yes
I thought mine entrance really huh let's
go for now
hello
sandi buddy out there
I'm scared I feel like Oh someone threw
up here
that's a big pile of throw-up I mean
puke
okay went in the box
sand erosion I need one of those nothing
else
the one who made this mod really hates
light cuz I never never gives it to me
not that night either
it's not fair okay I think we're done
here
but we need to go here or something so
many doors are you kidding me ah yeah
what is this uh it's a sister I love
sisters actually existed there my it
wasn't even a sister there we go there
we go
progress see how pretty awesome
sometimes but only sometimes I know I
know
share a chairs ah and barrels the
barrels
barrels are enough here requested on
whether that
I'm watching you alright let's read this
Oh No
the mind is crawling with them I'm not
going in there I don't like spiders nope
not one that they can have it I don't
care I have what I need from the mind
anyway I just hope I don't run out of my
math golly the little bastards are high
Cillian too no matter how many times I
call a massive lock on them they just
keep going they certainly aren't
anything like the spider from the former
here spiders actually light died when
you crush them
oh how I miss my formula I hope I will
see it again something yes they actually
died ah okay so I am come here yelling
it's blocked this is safe though I mean
I don't doubt it safe but yeah just
mmm-hmm found nothing do we have oil oh
yes yes but where do we go it's blocked
wait we still have the crowbar right
know mantis let's do hammer time we
can't do a hammer time
I wonder if I miss something no let's go
to mine actually yes Mike prioritize the
mine is over here mine is not over here
I was so sure
okay it's for Cherie over here that's
don't worry don't worry I got this
no problem just hope that frickin
monster doesn't appear like a split
second again I'm scared I'm scared I'm
scared I'm scared
is over here right yep I'm a genius I'm
Alfred Nobel mm-hmm I read comments
let's go
I just wanna bump into any spiders are
there any spiders in the first game I
don't I mean the original I mean there's
sweet I need that uh yeah just a random
chassis
I mean draw over here the mind the mind
is terribly confused maze it's hard to
maintain one spelling from the timing
fluid since everything looks so I like
for this listen I have noted the
location of the cinnabar vein and taking
the steps alleged followed by the hole
to the escape hatch necessary the
cinnabar vein is characterized by guile
are surrounded it in contrast to the
warlock of quwata mine the path is a
swallow first well left then right keep
left
I'm confused first left then the height
huh
keep left keep walking until there is
one or force fone extract the ore turn
180 degrees and follow the steps to
reach the skipper first left keep left
keep side then I blah I don't remember
ah
so found all these confusing notes but
let's go I'm part i bunk
yeah where's piggy I thought I heard him
Oh
yeah ask me what it feel like staring at
the sky so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie they say real life I'll be making
good on my promises honesty is pop it in
slot if it is missing but I realized I
could be better than I was lighter on my
feet cooking up the soul when we fire up